joining me now is jose castillo who is
currently a resort duty manager at the
walt disney company jose
are you concerned first and foremost
about your job your job security by
speaking out here tonight
hi laura thank you for having me on the
show uh honestly uh no it's no secret
here in central florida that i'm running
for congress that i'm a disney worker
and i'm a strong conservative to be
honest i'm not concerned about my job
because uh you know i i think if if i
were to get fired for my for my views uh
i think it would send a wrong message to
uh to uh conservatives you know that
conservative would not be welcome at
disney uh i i know that you know right
now it seems like there's a
misconception this is why i tell people
there's a misconception out there that
everyone in this needs just uh raging
liberals and that i i think that could
not be farther from the truth from my
perspective as a candidate running for
congress i have tons of people that work
for the walt disney company that reach
out to me daily on social media okay but
jose this is about this is about this
current story i'm glad you're happy at
disney but i can tell you what after
people saw what they saw in those videos
they're not happy at all so i'm glad
your job security's there good for you
but someone who is a traditional
conservative social conservative you
know serious
christian or frankly any other faith
is now being told that disney's purpose
political purpose is to ensure that
kindergarteners to third grade are
taught about sexual orientation that is
the hill that disney wants to die on
after making billions off of families
who are traditionalists
that's i think they're here that's the
problem i think
i think they're making a terrible
miscalculation that you know ultimately
may be back will be bad for business
their statement says this about the the
bill that ron desantis passed they said
our goal as a company is for the law to
be repealed by the legislator or struck
down by the courts and you know in the
left they talk about democracy after
this election and so what about our
democracy right now you know the people
of florida a lot of disney customers
voted for our state legislature these
are duly elected members of the florida
house of representatives the florida
senate who passed this bill send it to
the governor and thank god our governor
has the backbone to stand up to
companies like like like mine disney and
uh and pass this bill and stand with the
people of florida to stand with the
parents and protect our children well i
just i can't tell you how many people i
heard from today said they're never
going to walt disney world again they're
not going to disney world they're not
going to disneyland they're not going to
spend the thousands of dollars that are
asked they're charging at the star wars
experience at disney to essentially be
told they're a bunch of you know
anti-lgbt horrible awful rotten people
they're just they're just not going to
do that so i mean i guess disney can
cobble together their income from
non-traditional americans but that's
going to be a heavy lift now a new poll
is saying that a majority of florida
democrats support
its new parental rights bill so
democrats support the parental rights
bill the numbers are huge again
disney going with the far left
extremists which i can't imagine what
walt disney would think today
well you know the reason that's
happening is because really
there's a saying squeaky wheel gets the
grease and the small minority within the
walt disney company that's part of the
lgbt community are screaming the loudest
they're being the loudest they're being
the most vocal so we need conservatives
like me uh here you know i'm as a
candidate i've been as loud as i can
telling people that we need to stand up
for our conservative values and i'll be
doing the same in congress you know but
what disney fails to realize is that you
know we've gotten emails from our
executives saying their stance on on the
bill and whatnot and what people fail to
realize you know i knew where they stand
they stood already but there's a lot of
people that are just why would you want
but why would you want to work at a
company
where the company essentially thinks
that you're a bigot i mean what they
said essentially about ron desantis and
all the activists who supported what
disney did was that ron desantis was a
bigot
so i mean again the message to
traditional americans is you're not
welcome here that's the message disney
is sending out i'm going to say it very
clearly tonight everyone's walking
around this issue they do not think that
traditional americans should have a seat
at the table or frankly even be on
corporate boards i don't know how many
conservatives are on the court on the
board of disney today uh we should have
we should have put their names up on on
on television tonight but
i i think this is just the tip of the
iceberg and corporate america is going
to be in for a rude awakening thank you
jose we really appreciate speaking out
tonight hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else